ce que vous pouvez nous raconter
l'histoire de votre soeur donc guillen
qui rencontre son convoi en 2007 c'est
ça donc ma soeur rencontre effectivement
son conjoint 2007
assez rapidement et ils vivent ensemble
en 2010 et accueilli une petite fille
et puis les années passant une déviance
psychologique qui se met en place mais
c'est très insidieux et vers la fin de
cette relation avant le drame ma soeur
rencontre quelqu'un d'autre et monsieur
la prend dans les derniers jours et lui
fait beaucoup de chantage au suicide et
il m'en a fait part également à moi
aussi et le 22 septembre 2017 après une
dispute et il abat violemment élue des
verts ce contenu d'une bouteille
d'essence automobile sur le corps il met
le feu sur ma soeur devant leur petite
fille alors il est brûlé à 90%
elle va mourir deux jours plus tard à
l'hôpital leur fille de 7 ans assistent
à la scène
il raconte le papa est allé chercher une
bouteille d'essence et l'a renversée sur
maman alors est-ce qu'elle avait subi
des violences physiques avant ce qu'elle
vous en avez parlé je peux pas vous dire
parce que j'habitais pas vécu donc là
vous en avez géré par les allemands
n'avaient jamais parlé mais ni des
violences psychologiques
elle m'avait donné des vraiment des tout
petits signaux mais tellement faibles
que moi j'ai pas pris la mesure de ces
de ces violences c'est après que je m'en
suis rendu compte et notamment en
accueillant ma petite nièce sur la
maison où j'ai assisté à des scènes
complètement effarante
quant à la à des situations de la vie
quotidienne une phase effet une tâche de
crème au chocolat sur le pyjama
elle s'est mise à hurler je suis arrivé
je suis dit c'est pas grave on va
changer le pyjama
moi j'ai un petit garçon de 10 ans quand
il se fait une tache il essuie comme ça
il attend que je m'en rende compte que
je n'ai jamais changé son pyjama une
autre fois la renverser le dentifrice
dans le lavabo elle s'est mise à hurler
parce qu'elle avait gâché le dentifrice
et du coup je me c'est là que j'ai pris
la mesure en fait je me suis dit qu'il y
avait une pression psychologique à la
maison qui tue est folle mais elle a
raconté la petite aussi des choses
la vue bien sûr de la petite nous a
raconté tout ce qui s'est passé tout ce
qu'elle a vu le nous a dit que son papa
m'a dit qu'ils allaient tuer sa maman
elle a entendu ce n'est pas pas dire
c'est avoir le drame je veux dire dans
la vie quotidienne elles n'ont à aucun
moment été battu l apal a parlé au nom
n'a pas parlé de ça elle m'a raconté
qu'elle était recevait des punitions
quand elle faisait des bêtises alors des
punitions qui moi en tant que maman me
choque
une fois la fédé ligne parce qu'elle
avait couru après les pigeons dans la
rue quel enfant ne fait pas ça une autre
fois parce qu'elle avait trop éclaboussé
dans la salle de bain on avait mis trop
de voix là et c'est en me racontant ça
que moi j'ai pris la mesure de ce que
vivent un sort au quotidien mais avant
j'avais jamais rien vu moi j'insiste sur
le fait que ces idées y ait des hommes
qui ont vraiment deux visages ce
monsieur là c'est le parrain de mon fils
aîné on a fait un pub baptême
républicain et c'est le parent à mon
fils aîné alors justement qu'en est il
de son ex compagnon a alors il a été
gravement brûlée également dans
l'incendide ce soir-là il a été en
pronostic vital engagé
plusieurs semaines il a été extrêmement
bien soigné pendant ce temps et
aujourd'hui d'après les dires de ce que
murray me raconte ma petite nièce plus
que moi je ne demande jamais aucune
nouvelle de lui en est il de vous le
dire
elle me dit qu'aujourd'hui son papa il
remarche que et son frère du frère de
monsieur me dis que quand il habillé on
ne voit rien alors qu'il croisait dans
la rue vous savez pas qu'il a été volé
est-ce que ce qui est ce qu'ils revoient
ça va être à firhill n'est pas en prison
grand bien sûr à six années en prison
voire sur wii il a pris combien il est
incarcéré à leurs yeux procès se doit
ces vases 9 au 15 janvier c'est ça c'est
du 9 au 15 janvier 2020 et pour
l'instant il nie toujours les faits
voilà je vous dis mais voilà mais est-ce
que vous avez est ce que est ce qu'il a
voulu revoir sa fille non parce que ma
petite nièce étant le principal témoin
elie l'accusé je peux encore comment on
pourrait les mettre ensemble
alors vous élevez votre nièce depuis le
décès de votre de votre soeur est ce
qu'elle vous en parle elle en a beaucoup
parlé au départ à la raconter tout ce
qui s'était passé après la une parole
libérée chez moi donc dès qu'elle veut
nous parler
elle nous parle très librement là
maintenant on est un peu plus de deux
ans donc vous dit quoi sur son papa elle
me dit quoi sur son papa m'a qu'elle
aime toujours calé derrière qui va pas
rester longtemps en prison
les enfants ont une force de résilience
qu'on n'a pas forcément nous alors vous
avez unis fait citer avec nous tout le
23 novembre
pourquoi vous vous teniez à être là
parce que nos victimes sont les
premières en devant de la scène elles
sont mortes
donc c'était très symbolique de faire
voir aussi au gouvernement que on était
là malgré la perte de nos morte mais
manifestement j'ai l'impression qu'ils
ne sont pas vus